hello everyone and welcome to today's
second webinar in a three-part series
looking under the hood and getting
started with the Optima AED I'm Ross
where heel of Beckman Coulter life
sciences and I'll be moderating today's
live event I'd like to thank lab roots
for presenting today's webinar which is
brought to you by Beckman Coulter life
sciences a global leader in central
Gatien and life science instrumentation
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
I encourage you to participate by
answering a few poll questions during
the presentation and by submitting
questions for our speaker at any time to
do so simply type in the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits with
great pleasure I now present today's
speaker my friend and colleague Akash
Bhattacharya of Beckman Coulter life
sciences Tasha has extensive experience
in various biophysical characterization
methods including analytical
ultracentrifugation he's currently a
senior application scientists at Beckman
with a focus on expanding and developing
analytical ultracentrifugation
applications for Akash is complete bio
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen Akash please go ahead
and begin your presentation
thank you further introduction good
morning everyone I want to thank you for
attending our webinar now the first
webinar of this three-part series which
we had conducted earlier in June went
into the principles of analytical a
little simplification where we really
just described the technique to you and
gave you a very brief overview of few
application areas in this webinar we are
going to take a deeper dive into the
technology of auc itself and then we'll
be talking about the operational aspects
of planning setting up an experiment and
viewing a live data webinar number three
which will be in the first quarter of
2020 will go deeper into some other
application areas as well okay so let's
get started before we do so we have to
show you it's light with various legal
disclaimers on it and now that you've
seen it let's move on so a roadmap for
today's conversation is going to be
first we'll talk about the technical
evolution of a you see the technique
then we'll give you an overview of the
workflow of a typical biochemistry
project and talk about interference
detection versus absorbance detection
then we'll talk about the upgrades and
advantages that the new generation
Beckman Coulter Optima auc brings to the
table especially in comparison to the
previous generation proteome lab up a UT
instrument after that we'll move on to
planning an experiment where we show you
the use of simulation tools so that you
can best design the parameters to get an
experiment which is as informative as
possible and then we'll show you the
operational aspect of actually setting
up an experiment only a new optima
instrument and then of course will
summarize everything and give you some
additional information about user group
meeting things and so on and so forth
all right so let's get started
so
this is sort of a folk history of the
technique of analytical
ultracentrifugation now 1926 tail thread
work received the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry for his study of colloids the
technique that he used was what we today
called analytical ultracentrifugation or
aut it's really interesting that while
said we receive the Nobel Prize in 1926
in chemistry the same year the Opera
also received the Nobel Prize in Physics
and his prize was awarded for the study
of sedimentation equilibrium which
really forms the theoretical
underpinning of designs of a you see so
finely fascinating that in 1926 the
Swedish Academy chose to recognize both
the theoretical as well as the
experimental aspects of the syntactic
technique that has been so strong and
powerful to all videos a few years later
in the late 1930s only LOM wrote down a
partial differential equation similarly
a transport equation which described the
movement of analyte inside the sector
shaped shell shaped cell so I'm using
this world sector shape I'll show you in
a few slides what that actually means
but this really forms the mathematical
basis for the understanding of what
happens during an AUC experiment however
writing down this equation was only the
start it would be many years in fact
decades until the computational ability
to solve this equation became available
to us the next major development
occurred from the hardware and from the
commercial hardware standpoint when
Edward pickles ducks with a company
called spinkle stood for specialized
instrument corporation the acronym was
very appropriate because he built
centrifuges and he built the famous
model east centrifuge analytical
ultracentrifugation physics and
biochemistry so fundamental in fact that
a few years after the acquisition
of spinkle by Beckman in 1954 level to
install conducted an experiment where
they proved that the application of DNA
is semiconservative and this is the
fundamental implications in genetics
this experiment is in fact frequently
described as the most elegant
experiments conducted in all of
experimental biology and it was
conducted using an analytical a
centrifuge the next major development in
this field occurred again in the late
1950s at Berkeley I believe when Shakman
devised the interferometric detection
system but the previous method of
detection was essentially absorption
photography in the parametric detection
which we will talk about in a little bit
more technical video shortly there was a
different type of detection where
anything which provided a refractive
index difference between two sectors
would actually lead to an image and
thereafter lead to an actual peak and it
turned out to be an extraordinarily
sensitive technique and allowed a lot of
new areas to be analyzed via a UC
following these hardware developments
the next major development in this field
occurred in the late 1970s when van hold
and team came up with what we today call
these and hold why should graphical
analysis this is a fascinating thing
because the solution of old Adams
partial differential equation is in fact
a computationally very difficult and
challenging task the van hold why should
graphical and analysis technique makes
this very difficult computational
problem and turns it into a graphical
problem which is still very laborious to
solve but significantly more tractable
even with the very limited computational
abilities
available to most scientists in the late
1970s now again in the 1990s the
the next phase of development swung back
from analysis back to hard work and this
occurred with the release of the
proteome lab and vertical alpha
centrifuge instrument by Beckman Coulter
this was a gigantic and dramatic
improvement over the previous generation
model II one of the reasons that well so
is because the model II fantastic and
flexible instrument so it was they'd
occupy the better part of a room its
footprint would simply huge the proteome
lab on the other hand which many of you
have actually seen and worked on is
something which is the size of a
domestic washing machine
now fast forward a few years again and
in the late 1990s another huge
improvement in analysis occurred with
the development of two software packages
one of them is called set fit this was
developed by Peter shook who is at B NIH
the other is called alpha scan this is
developed by Boris damn nur who is
currently at the University of
Lethbridge both of these software
packages essentially provide numerical
solutions to the Lamb equation and they
are widely used in the user community
and this this really was the analysis
milestone which the user community has
been waiting for for perhaps half a
century
ever since the original lamb equation
was written down for software to become
available which would take advantage of
the tremendous computing power which we
see in today's personal computers to
actually solve this fairly difficult
computational problem fast forward again
a few years and in nineteen twenty
sixteen Beckman Coulter released the
brand-new Optima analytical as the
centrifuge and at the risk of using a
somewhat cliched expression this really
is a quantum leap in improvement in the
technology itself for one thing the
detection methodology and the detectors
have been dramatically upgraded the user
interface itself is now platform
agnostic I will explain what that means
in a few minutes and is far far simpler
to use and this has allowed this
technique to now make inroads into a
whole new level of application areas but
it really hasn't been used very
effectively before some of those
application areas include for example
lentiviruses a ve capsid fundamental in
gene therapy therapeutic verticals
therapeutic liposome nanoparticles and
many others and this is actually a good
point for me to pause and hand over
control to my colleague draweth so that
he can push out the first poll question
which is connected to application areas
just over to you
thanks Akash so our first a question is
you better understand our audience's
background so with that for which
primary application area are you here to
learn about AUC we'll pause for just a
moment
you
you
okay Akash if you want to go ahead and
please continuous presentation thank you
lot okay so now that we've given you
sort of a folk history of AEP let's move
on and talk about the workflow so again
in the first webinar of this series
which incidentally is available in
recorded form and at the end of this
webinar you will be shown the link to
get to that we talked about an
introduction to aut
and we discussed its overview
capabilities and compared it to a few
other wise people to give you examples
now if you are getting started with it
brand new biochemistry project then you
have some information before you get to
the point where you want to do a UC
specifically you've probably done some
questions but you've run some SDS pages
you've done some size-exclusion
chromatography in order to get a pure or
as pure as possible recombinant protein
ready and now you want to do a UC so
before you do aut
you're going to ask a few questions
about experiment design you will not say
do I want to detect with absorbance or
interference or both then if you're
going to want to detect with absorbance
next question you'll ask yourselves it
sure I want to do absorbance what we're
going to I want to use so now that
you've got the first questions answered
then you would like to get some idea of
what data you will eventually expect to
see so in order to do that you would
like to run some simulations in order to
predict the sedimentation coefficient of
the analyte of interest so you've done
some simulations we've got these answers
ready which has given you these
parameters that you want to use for the
actual experiment setup now we come to
the actual experiment setup but for that
you are going to assemble itself once
the cells are completely assembled
you're going to fill them up with sample
and once that's done you will load the
assembled and filled itself into a rotor
which is perfectly balanced you'll stick
the rotor on top of the spindle close
the lid and then you'll walk back to
your control laptop where you want me to
program in a method which is specific
and has the exact parameters that you
chose from the simulation we'll come
back to the instrument
the touchscreen and then just hit go and
your experiment is off and running once
the experiment is completed or once the
experiment is ongoing you'll go back to
your control laptop you'll monitor the
data as it comes in and once the
experiment is done you'll download the
data and analyze it react your favorite
software package
okay so
we did this which I did mention that
there are two different detection
techniques available on the Optima I use
the absorbance as well as interference
and let's talk about the advantages and
disadvantages of these two techniques so
absorbance it's fairly easy to
understand what the physics of this
technique is it's essentially UV
absorbance as you have used in n UV
expect in your lab but perhaps an alga
it works on the principle that you've
got some photons coming through and
these photons are going to be obscured
by the presence of analyte and
absorbance is calculated via the
equation ABB's equals minus log I sample
by I left but I sample is the intensity
of photons coming in sample I def is the
intensity of light coming in to just
buffer and that gives me the adult now
the advantage with absorbance detection
is that you can very specifically pick
the wavelength of interest so if you
have a combination of different analyte
and you know that you really want to see
the behavior of one analyte inside the
combination and you know that it absorbs
say at 480 or 490 nanometers you can
mark the detection wavelength exactly at
480 490 or whatever that was and observe
the behavior only this analyte this
selectivity is a tremendous advantage
especially in a crowded mixture of
different things in your sample tube how
long does it take to detect the Optima
AUC is much faster than the previous
generation in human however you are
still restricted to about maximum of 20
seconds of scanning time perfect
in comparison to this the physics of
interference detection is a very similar
duty it's basically connected to the
classic Young's double-slit experiments
which every physics student has read
about in a web wave optics lab the idea
there is that light passes through both
the sample sector and the reference
sector and I'll show you what those
things look like in just a moment and if
there is an optical path length
difference between these two sectors
well you get what is known as the fringe
pattern and as the analyte sediments
over time cost of an experiment this
fringe pattern moves this movement of
the fringe pattern is converted to an
actual scan which is what you are
eventually going to end up focusing
offline so anything which creates a
optical path length difference is going
to show up in the form of a fringe this
creation of an optical path length
difference occurs because the refractive
index in one sector is different from
the refractive index in another this is
out in the photometric detector to
actually be significantly more sensitive
than the absorbance vector
however this sensitivity comes at the
cost of selectivity in other words if
there's anything in the interferometric
detector which creates a refractive
index difference between the two sectors
that will show up as a French and that
fringe will eventually show up as a scan
and the scan will eventually show up as
a spurious peak so in other words and
also to get the very best quality data
that you possibly can out of the
interferometric detector you really have
to make sure that the buffer is matched
as carefully as possible in fact perhaps
even more carefully than you would match
by doing an IDC experiment if you do so
then you will not have this problem of
studious peaks and you will have all of
the advantages of the extraordinary
sensitivity of this detector but you
will not be seeing any spooky s Peaks
the other advantage of the
interferometric detector is that it's
significantly faster in fact you can get
down to perhaps as quick as
five seconds per scan I believe so there
are both advantages and disadvantages to
both techniques and
the one you choose is really going to
depend on what you want to do and for
example if you wanted to record data on
something which is very large such as a
virus capsid and you thought that it is
something which is going to settlement
very quickly in an experiment you may
want to go for interferometric detection
simply because it is that much faster
okay which again brings us to the second
poll question what I'm going to hand
over control to Roth
where he can push this question of view
yes
alright thanks again Akash our second
question is regarding the preferred
detection methods of the audience in
your primary workflows so which
detection methods are critical in your
primary application area and again we'll
give just a moment to pause before we
get back to the presentation
you
okay Akashi if you want to go ahead and
continue on with the presentation
Thank You dot okay let's move on so now
let's spend a moment looking at the
advantages with which the Optima you see
brings to the table especially in
comparison to previous generation
instrument so first off the Optima IEP
has significantly faster scan rates in
fact at least three times faster than
the previous generation instrument and
impact is sometimes more depending on
the rotor speed as well now we come to
the number of wavelengths in the
previous generation instrument you
really could just get only one reliable
wavelength you could try to get a few
more but reliably speaking you only end
up just getting a single monochromatic
detection in the new generation
instrument this is no longer the case
you can as a matter of fact get up to 20
different wavelengths on a single expand
and this multi-wavelength detection is
exceptionally important especially if
you're dealing with complex systems such
as proteins nucleic acid combinations
and it allows for the possibility of
global fitting and obtaining biophysical
parameters for which you would have to
run perhaps five or six different
experiments but now you only run a
single experiment with multi-wavelength
action it is an amazing advantage which
the optimize we have brought to the
biophysics field but I in terms of the
precision of the wavelength in
comparison to previous instrument where
the wavelength was guaranteed to three
nanometers now it's guaranteed to 0.5
nanometers and it does this radial
resolution well earlier you would get
data sampled at 30 micron intervals on
the radial axis now you get data sampled
it 10 micron intervals on the radial
axis in other words you get three times
as much data as before and you still get
it faster in terms of the
interferometric system earlier you used
to have only about four fringes per cell
now you have greater than ten in fact
numbers a little bit close to sixteen
fringes per cell but the big advantage
as well and in terms of the actual
usability of the instrument the previous
generation instrument did not have a
touchscreen it had a monochromatic small
7-inch control screen and was connected
to a fixed windows versions computer
which you
not have a choice in upgrading as well
now you have the system control via an
onboard that screen and it has its own
internal operating system but all of the
actual programming of a new method can
occur offline up and so not offline but
not on the instrument but via your own
control laptop sitting in your office
nap control laptop can be a Windows
machine it can be a Mac it can be a
Linux box as long as you've got Chrome
or Firefox and you can connect via
browser to the instrument you can
control the instrument so that's what I
meant when I said the Optoma AUP is
essentially platform agnostic and you
won't ever have to worry about
supporting and old and fixed version of
Windows anymore so but these advantages
we hope to be optimal IFE will bring a
lot more convenient to your experiments
and your science and in terms of
actually doing an experiment this is
something which the people who've worked
on the older protein lab instrument in
particular are going to really really
appreciate putting the detector into
place after you've loaded the rotor on
top of the spindle is as simple as
turning these two knobs on the sides of
the centrifuge bucket when you do so the
pre-mounted absorbance and
interferometric detectors swing into
position you close the lid and that's it
gives it to go in start your experiment
let's take a brief look at the journey
to go from sample to data so if you've
got an assembled cell as shown in the
top bangle figure and you used a 10 stem
pipette to load up sample into it then
you would stick the cell inside the
rotor make sure it's balanced put the
rotor on top of the spindle what happens
then the rotor when it's sitting on top
of the spindle is exposed to this optics
arrangement we're in a light source as
it happens if you non flash sense light
via a number of fold middles up and down
through the two windows and through the
center piece that is to say through the
cell and through the actual sample
itself and down below where it hits a
detector that detector happens to be a
photomultiplier do all that does is that
it takes of light converted into a
voltage and what you are essentially get
out is that number that I was talking
about before which is intensity counts
that intensity counts can thereafter be
converted into an actual absorbance
number and you've also got this radial
slit it's the movement of this radial
slit which gives you the data which is
separated at ten micron intervals so
really the data that you're getting out
of an ADC experiment ultimately comes
down to on the y-axis you expect to see
some kind of absorbance number and on
the x-axis you expect to see some kind
of radial distance in centimeters that
is the figure which you're seeing on the
bottom right panel and when you do so
you will want to know what does an
actual data scan look like and that is
what we explained in the moment so if
you look at the top right panel you will
see that this is a schematic view of
looking vertically down upon the two
sectors of an AUC cell the left sector
which is shaded in light is the
reference sector and all you've got
there is just buffer and nothing else
the right sector which has these two
different colors three different colors
red cyan and dark blue is the sample
sector and let's explain what these
three colors mean so the first color red
we've got nothing there that's the air
gap in other words there is no sample
there's no buffers is just air but if
you've got just air you don't really
expect any absorbance at all therefore
this region should have an absorbance of
zero and that is
exactly what is shown in the region
marked air gap in the bottom right panel
of the absorbance plot now after the air
gap you have the siren the tire region
corresponds to where you've got a buffer
but you do not have any actual analyte
now again
buffer if it is properly matched up
against the reference sector should also
have leader absorbance so the buffer
only region as shown in cyan in the
absorbance plot also has an absorbance
value of zero units however the
transition from the area to the buffer
region occurs via email if occur
now the meniscus is for various reasons
a region of opacity in an absorbance
experiment so that is seen as a spike in
the absorbance value as you planted from
the air-gap to the buffer now what about
the last region the last region towards
the bottom of the sector is shown in
dark blue this is the region where
you've got sampled now one people sample
over here this sample is at a constant
concentration because this is a velocity
experiment we're talking about and not
an equilibrium experiment and this
constant concentration means that in the
absorbance plot you should really see
this as a flat plateau and that's
exactly what you see in the buffer plus
analyte marked out region where he's got
an absorbance value of approximately 0.5
now here's the interesting thing the
transition between the buffer only
region and the buffers analyzed region
is something which we call the boundary
of this experiment so if there was no
diffusion of the buffer at all this
boundary would be nothing but a simple
step function however in practical terms
it is always going to be some
thermodynamic diffusion and therefore
this boundary has a beautiful etched
shape that you see in the absorbance
plot and as the experiment progresses
more and more analyte moves towards the
bottom of the cell therefore this
boundary keeps moving towards the right
of the cell and it is the movement and
the shape of this boundary which really
contains all of the essential
mathematics of a EC which is then
converted into the peak distributions
that you typically see in a publication
this in a nutshell is how you go from
sample to data in an AC experiment okay
bring on I want to show you a actual
real-life case study of the Optima a you
see that compared to the previous
proteome lab instrument this is an
example of data acquired on an
adeno-associated virus or a ap sample
and these two experiments on these two
instruments we're done using samples
from the same freezer box from the same
prep which was just adequate without
separate so the speed for this
experiment was eighteen thousand five
hundred rpm rotor speed for both
instruments as you can see the proteome
lab instrument essentially just give you
if you maybe twelve useful scans before
everything sediments because it's not
very fast an acquisition the optimality
instrument which is the right panel give
you three times as much data in fact it
gives you about thirty five also useful
scans for everything sediment now this
is just a raw data but it's fairly
obvious that you get three times as many
scans as before
in the new generation instrument now
when I went out and processed all of
this I also found that the after
processing the actual RMS B of the
Optima instrument is one-third the rmsd
of the older proteome lab engine so the
new instrument is does not just give you
faster data it also gives you
significantly cleaner data this is of
course very important if you're working
in gene therapy where you're working
with risky large analytes and you want
as many scans as possible for everything
sediment and that is a good segue into
moving into our next section where we
talk about experimental simulations
things you must do before you get
started so in this I want to get into
simulations we are two different case
studies what are these two cases the
first is a two component antibody
case study where the first component
which provides
70% of the total signal in this system
is a 50 kilo Dalton fragment of an
antibody the remaining 30% of the signal
comes from a be 150 kilo thousands full
and complete antibody this simulation
was carried out using separate 16.2
related okay the second case study
concerns a three-component
adeno-associated by that system the
three components are 1/3 MP capsid 1/3
captured filled with half of the genome
partial genome look and 1/3 of the
capsid filled with the complete genome
this simulation case studies was carried
out using auto scan 3 for Windows
specifically the finite element
calculators inside of the scheme ok
let's talk about simulation case 1 you
are interested in choosing the
curricular speed so for the purposes of
this simulation
I asked set fit to generate 50 scans for
me which are separated at 300 second
interval and I said let's do it at
several different other speeds so the
first figure that you see on the top
left is at it acquired at 20 kilo rpm
and all you see here is in compute
sedimentation as well as inadequate
separation as you increase the rotor
speed to 25 kilowatt I am giving all the
other parameters the same you see that
the sedimentation is somewhat more
complete but it's really not there yet
then the separation is also in adequate
when you get all the way up to 40 kilo
rpm now you start seeing something very
interesting what you see is that there
are two plateaus one of the plateaus you
the eagle-eyed observer will also notice
occupies about seventy percent of the
total day signal height the other
plateau corresponds to about 30% of the
total signal height and also appeals to
correspond to a slower moving species
also you kind of have to squint to see
now this is very interesting because it
tells you even we are a direct visual
inspection that there are at least two
distinct species in this data set even
without processing it now it at all this
is something which you can figure out
even looking at just the raw data
however you can still tell that since
this data hasn't completely sedimented
yet the experiment for all practical
purposes is not yet complete so
separation is kind of adequate with the
sedimentation is incomplete now if you
Jack the speed up to 50 kilo rpm you see
this amazing thing well these two
plateaus are beautifully distinctly
visible and separate and all of the
actual sample has sedimented so any
further scans that you are going to be
acquiring
to be essentially just baseline camp and
baseline can't really just useless to
you so what you have here is perfect
separation and complete sedimentation
and this I would count as a really
well-designed experiment we've acquired
all of the data that you need and you're
not wasting experiment time and
acquiring useless data beyond this
remember to follow a rule of thumb
resolution always increases with rotor
speed and experiment duration will
determine whether the sample is fully
sedimented provided that the scan number
and the scan line separation is
something that is previously set up and
fixed okay
let's look at the second case study so
over here
component vital system we want to
balance speed scans as well as
resolution so what I did was I ran
simulations on this three component
system on an entire range of rotor speed
going from five kilo rpm all the way up
to 50 kilo rpm if you're restricting
yourself Louis rotor speed such as five
kilo rpm you get the stress on the right
hand side plot which is shown in red but
you barely see the main peak separated
perhaps into two components the
separation is really bad however if you
go all the way up to 40 kilo rpm you see
three completely clearly distinctly
separated peaks and the separation is
all the way down to the baseline this is
amazing you started off with three occur
three component system and you see three
peaks which are separated all the way
down to the baseline so the question
really is what is the raw data look like
so if you look at the left the bottom
panel at 40 kilo rpm you've got three
distinct levels over there the lowermost
plateau
corresponds to empty gap it's the second
plateau occurs wants to halfway loaded
gaps and the third plateau corresponds
to fully loaded cancel so I really
wanted to show you that even the visual
inspection overall data as shown on the
left hand side panel it can actually be
fairly informative with a little bit of
experience because you know what you're
eventually going to see plenty from
fully burst of the data it's a good plan
B check another loop if you were to
reduce the speed down to 19 kilo rpm and
instead get a lot more scans instead
which can of course do then yeah you
really really have to squint in order to
answer the question how many plateaus
are there you cannot really say that the
distinct letters are distinct be visible
so a far AAV captured samples I would
actually suggest that you run at a
minimum speed of 22 kilo rpm in this
case is probably okay to optimize for
rotor speed and into the scans and of
course you will be happy to know for all
gene therapy customers that the Optima I
use three scans at least three times
faster than the previous generation
proteome lab instrument
okay so now that you've looked at how to
use simulation tools in order to get the
experiment parameters and by experiment
parameters really what you need is how
many scans do I want what is the time
separation I want in my scans and what's
the rotor speed I want now let's talk
about how you actually set up an AC
experiment the nitty-gritty of
operations so you've got a choice of
rotors on the left hand side panel this
is what your actual after my UC
instrument looks like on the right side
you've got a picture of two different
rotors if you want the throughput
advantage of an eight whole rotor then
you can pick the eight hold water
unfortunately you're restricted to a
maximum speed of 50 kilo rpm but this is
usually completely just fine
for most all applications however if
you're working specifically with small
molecules and you really need that
additional bit of separation which you
can only get by pushing the speed up to
sixty kilo rpm then you should be
working with the forward hold rotor
which is rated to sixty kilo rpm and we
also do sell aluminum centerpieces which
are also rated to sixty kilo rpm so
advantage here is speed and the
advantage for the eight hold rotor is to
put
so about cell assembly and loading this
sample itself is loaded inside these
centerpieces remember when I had said
earlier in the talk that over a lumped
equation describe the movement open and
light inside a sector shape this is what
the sector shape looks like it is called
so because it quite literally is the
sector of a circle the sample is loaded
inside the sector shape where the sample
loading goals shown by the red colored
arrow
enterpise before you actually load the
sample you're going to assemble the
complete cell the Assembly of the cell
occurs in the following fashion you take
the center piece and you bracket it via
these two windows top and bottom you
create a sandwich the center piece is
right in the middle and everything is
loaded inside of this aluminum housing
but you then put a gasket on top and
then excluding tighten the screw ring
and use this dark arrangement where you
talk it up to 120 inch pounds and
therefore make it completely leak proof
and then you go back and load the sample
into the cell via these narrow stem
pipette tips once the sample is loaded
you fill up the loading holes with a
gasket and then a brass plug and then
you are ready to weigh the total self
balances against another cell put it
inside of the rotor and once the rotor
is completely filled up and balanced you
can put the rotor on top of the spindle
you turn the detectors into position by
rotating these two knobs on the side of
the centrifuge bucket and then you push
the armored laid closed you hit the
vacuum button and you're good to go you
can start your experiments at that point
you've hit the vacuum button but you
want to program a brand new method I've
mentioned a couple of words about the
control of an Optima IEP now the control
works in the following fashion as
compared to the previous generation
instrument but you had to have a
computer tied to the Procyon lab usually
sitting right next to it and that
computer operated on a very specific old
version of Windows which you then had to
maintain in this case things a lot
simpler for you this is because the
programming of a new method really the
control of methods and scans etcetera
etc is going to occur via what we call a
control computer this control computer
can be a Mac PC a Linux box whatever you
want to and as long as it is within the
allowed IP addresses recognized by the
optima instrument and for the purposes
of this our service team will work with
your IT department to get this set up
the Optima AUC doesn't care what the
control computer is all it cares about
is that the control occur via browser
from that control laptop now if you've
got Chrome or Firefox in your laptop
you're good to go so you just type in a
I P address into the address bar of your
browser and you end up be lucky looking
at the splash screen for the Optima you
see on this map screen you have a number
of buttons on the left hand side going
from system status all the cell's view
is whether there's an experiment running
if so at what speed it monitors the
temperature hit more on it was the
vacuum the next button down is method
scans which we will use to program in a
specific method or to just select an
older method and copy it and give it a
new name and run it this is course
important if you're working inside a GMP
environment
then you have the live data tab where
you will look at the data as it coming
in as it's been acquired on the
instrument and that the fake data tab
allows you to save and convert the data
into a tarball and downloaded for
offline analysis and then of course
you've got symbols system settings and
so on and so forth okay so viewing the
live data now you can view live data
from the absorbance module in both
absorbance mode which is what we are
usually accustomed to viewing or you may
even want to view it in intensity mode
where what it gives you is the actual
intensity counts which is read off
before to multiply the arrangement
now if you look at just the absorbance
camp then you see a panel as you will
see on the top left side and that is an
example of a data set collected but all
of the scans are being is up but if you
want to collect every temp scan and
space it out a little bit then you have
the bottom left panel picture well again
it's absorbance data but collected only
every dance camp because of sponding
intensity images for that particular
sample sector are shown on the top right
and every tenth intensity scan is shown
on the bottom right and you'll note that
this in in a sort of a very hand-waving
mathematical way it's kind of the
inverse of the absorbance image but of
course the equation to convert it is not
exactly an inverse it's a logarithmic
equation but I find the intensity scan
image to also be very informative
because sometimes you can debug things
fairly easily by looking at the
intensity scan image
now there might be a situation where you
have a lot more sample inside the sample
factor then you had originally
anticipated and if you do so then the
sample might effectively be really dark
and by dark I mean that not a whole lot
of photons are going through and if that
is the case then the absorbance detector
is going to be saturated now this
saturation occurs at about an absorbance
value of it's about three units if that
occurs then this is what the absorbance
data looks like on the top left side
panel if you see scans which look like
this your detected saturated and this
experiment is really not going to work
if you look at the intensity data for a
saturated detector you see the top right
height panel where everything is just
flattened out at zero and again that
tells you that not a whole lot of
photons are coming through this
experiment will not only be used now you
can do more than just to get the
absorbing theta you can also look at the
interference data what does that look
like
so I told you that the interference data
actually these raw data itself is
available to you in the form of fringes
because it is connected to this classic
experiment of the Young's double-slit
experiment and wave optics so you really
do have the opportunity to look at the
fringe images and that is what is shown
to you on the bottom right side now
these fringe images are fully air and
form and then they turn into actual scan
which are shown to you on the bottom
left side so you have the opportunity to
both look at the interference scan data
as well as the actual images I
frequently find it useful to look at the
interference images because in some
cases they can be very very useful for
troubleshooting various things in your
experiment okay now that you've seen the
live data and your experiment is
complete you want to export the data
that's a sample of going into the saved
data tab kicking off the experiment of
interest collecting which cell you want
or selecting all of the cells and then
just hitting the export button at which
point the optima iup
will convert all of that data into a
star gzip file which you can then
download and use for offline analysis
it's worth mentioning
over here the previous-generation
instrument the proteome lab either
recorded absorbance data for you or
recorded intensity data for you if you
wanted both absorbance and intensity
data files at the same time that
instrument did not have the option of
giving lappy in this case we optimized a
UC will give you both absorbance data
files as well as intensity data files
and in some cases you may actually find
it useful to go with the intensity data
files because you can do pseudo what is
known as fuel absorbance analysis with
that and you can double the throughput
we'll talk about that in webinar number
three it's also worth noting that the
DAR gzipped arrangement will also
generate a file which has all of the
image files in it from the
interferometric detector now this is
interesting because you can look at
those image files and like I said
diagnose things even offline but just by
looking at those files and since the
image file tends to be pretty large in
fact it can easily exceed a gig it's
going to be a separate file
okay let's summarize everything we
talked about the Optima iuc is an
amazing instrument which offers your
multi-wavelength absorbent up to 20
different wavelengths as well as
simultaneous
interferometric detectors detection the
system controls it via an onboard screen
methods scans can be set up remotely
using your laptop which can have your
preferred operating system and your
preferred browser as long as your
preferred browser is either Chrome or
Firefox that we don't make any
guarantees with Abbey Safari you can
copy previously loaded method scans or
create a new one live data can be viewed
remotely via the browser you can look at
absorbance camp intensity scans as well
as interference fringe images you can
compress and download the data for our
flame analysis using your favorite
software now I want to leave you with
this experimental design rule of thumb
high rotor speed is always going to
improve the resolution between different
analytes more scans on an experiment
will improve the reproducibility of your
data adding additional baseline scans
want everything has balloted is not
really useful to you so if you do have
an experiment where you are acquiring a
lot of baseline scamp it's worthwhile
just tossing those scans when you go to
analysis or you could just stop your
experiment once one for live data map to
show you that everything has been it'll
because you're essentially done at that
point
okay so I am going to tell you what the
third poll question is while Roth pushes
it out and the third poll question is
the following after attending this
webinar what additional information
would you like to receive about
analytical identification if you have
additional comments you can type those
comments in as well and let's give you
some additional info before we finish up
the recording for webinar number one
which was earlier in tune is available
at this link shown the third webinar is
coming up in the first quarter of 2020
also on lab loop my colleague Roth
within the moderator for this event is
going to deliver a webinar himself his
talk is going to be on optimizing
density gradient preparatory of alpha
simplification in the gene therapy Kahn
sex this will be live on the 19th of
November 2019
please look out for emails as well as
announcements on LinkedIn
our next user group meeting is at the
University of Pennsylvania School of
Medicine this isn't the 15th of October
and the registration link is down below
and we invite all of you to come visit
our booth at the 2020 biophysical
Society meeting which will be in San
Diego in February of next year the link
is down below and finally I'd like to
thank you all for your attention we'll
be taking questions but before we do so
I'd like to leave you with this one
quotation from Taylor Edwards delivered
as part of his noble lecture but he says
that in the context of a UC the limit of
the portable has not yet been reached
thank you very much everyone
plus over to you
- for your great presentation on
in-depth operation of the modern ADC we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
this webinar as a reminder submit
questions by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
let's get started with the first
question so Akash how do I safely handle
biohazardous materials like viral
vectors in the AEC
okay great question this is something
that several of our customers have been
working with so the first thing is that
you can order an AUC which is fitted
with the HEPA filter this is very useful
because that makes sure that viral
vectors will not be atomized and
released into the lab now there are
various other protocols but essentially
if you're working with brand-new
equipment which is well maintained you
should not have a leak at all and if you
do then the cleanup procedures for this
are well documented there are a few CDT
documents which you can look up there
are a few protocols essentially just
clean everything and you're good to go
okay thank you the next question is
around the cell assembly where the
question is asked is how difficult is it
to assemble the multiple components of
the cell assembly okay so yeah so AUC is
literally a technique with several
moving parts right the cell assembly is
not difficult at all it is a fairly
straightforward technique and all it
takes is a little bit of practice and if
you're working with a well maintained
and new equipment and you just have had
a little bit of practice you will have
perfect cell assemblies which never leak
and give you exceptional data
okay great the next question is how do I
select the best wavelength for detection
- wavelength alright so for this what we
suggest you do is before you conduct the
experiment put your sample in a UV spec
or the nanodrop or what happens rather
instrument you would like to and record
the UV second and if you do so you will
see which of what are what are the Peaks
which you might be interested in
typically if you're working with a
protein nucleic acid combination the
dial thing tryptophan side chains will
of course have a peak at 280 nanometers
any nucleic acid will have a major peak
at 260 nanometers the protein itself
even if it doesn't have a whole lot of
tyrosine and tryptophan and therefore
doesn't have a peak at 280 the peptide
bonds will have a peak at 222 30
nanometers you can go down there as well
if you're working with anything which
has a fluorescent bag attached to it
typical floral fools of the Electra
family or v C for example will absorb at
490 nanometers so just put it on a UV
spec and you will immediately know what
wavelength you wanted to take that and a
number with the optima you see it's a
multi wavelength instrument so you're
not restricted to just detecting at one
wave you can go up to 20
all right sounds good the next question
we have is are there situations in which
the RPMs or the speed can actually be
too high
yes there are situations when that can
be the case if you are working with the
viral vectors or large nanoparticles
anything with sediments really fast and
you've jacked the speed up to the point
where you barely have dense camp before
everything sediments then you don't have
a whole lot of data and you can still
browse and scans but in order to have
reproducibility you would like to have
more scans than that this is where the
simulation tools in tight fit and ultra
can both come in handy you can predict
what your actual data will look like
before you ever plan on Excel actually
perform the experiment
okay thank you next question we have is
is the AUC currently being used in cGMP
environments in biopharma okay so the
aut is currently used in a GMP
environment by several of Howlett lines
and they have their own in-house SOPs to
make that happen we are aware that
certain improvements or modifications
have to be made in order to make the
instruments will be GMP compliant and we
are moving in that direction and which
actually brings me to an important point
that while providing feedback for this
webinar or just by emailing us directly
using our contact information if you
have suggestions which will help make
the instrument GMP compliant for your
specific application area or work so
please let us know these will be very
useful for us moving forward
okay the next question we have is more
forward-looking and asked what are you
seeing as current trends and
applications most benefiting from the
AEC
so AUC has okay to listen to this
question in two parts right so AC has
always been sort of a Swiss Army knife
in biophysics and this is the way it has
been treated and understood by the
academic research community it's
something which answers questions
connected to binding constants
aggregation molecular shape a whole
number of other things in fact it gives
you more information than usually an
entire lab full of other biophysics
techniques however in the industry
context that they see has seen a
renaissance figure and it's now seeing
in almost application any areas ranging
from gene therapy and especially AV
preparations it's also extremely useful
in looking at therapeutic methods such
as Terra Beauty lysosomes to the beauty
exosomes and of course it's very very
useful in looking at nanoparticles which
is also very interesting in the
therapeutic context PC
okay thank you so it looks like we're
starting to run a little short on time
so I'll ask you one more question before
we wrap up and that question is for
interacting system how do you decide on
the concentration of the component okay
so if for an interacting system how do
you decide on the concentration so I'm
assuming that you're talking about the
system where the you really want to find
out the KB of interaction between a
component a and component B so if you
want to do that kind of experiment
ideally you would look at an entire
decade's worth of concentration
differences if you're looking at protein
systems then you would really want to
run experiments which go from tenfold
below the expected KD and above as well
if you can and in doing so you will take
advantage of multi-wavelength detection
and try detecting at 280 nanometers to
20 nanometers when the concentration is
really low and just try to span left or
minus the KD an entire decade
okay thank you gosh do you have any
final comments to leave with our
audience
AC is an extremely powerful technique
it's really a Swiss Army knife and the
limits of what you can do imitate by you
know your own imagination so if you've
got an easy experiment that you want to
talk to us about or if you've got an
application area where you think you
need support feel free to reach out to
me and draw and we'll be happy to help
you get started
right Akash thank you again for taking
the time to discuss the operation of the
optimum ATC I'd like to also again thank
laborat and our sponsor Beckman Coulter
life sciences before we go I'd like to
finally thank the audience for joining
us today and participating questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information provided at the time
of registration when the webinar
recording is available for replay you
will receive an email from Webber's and
I encourage you to share that recording
with any colleagues who may have missed
today's live event I hope to see you
again at our upcoming webinars and
events until then take care